notice anything maybe Waldo they see
horse perhaps how about now ah there
that's the incredible pygmy seahorse a
true master of camouflage it's so tiny
it can fit on your fingernail but here's
the weird thing
the seahorse isn't born looking like a
red or orange or purple coral a pygmy
seahorse is born black and only changes
to match its surroundings when it lands
on the coral that doesn't make a lick of
sense most camouflages are born looking
like the places they hide it some color
changes like this cuttlefish can adjust
their settings with cells called
chromatophores but the pygmy seahorse
scientists haven't a clue but at least
they know why the seahorse evolved its
camouflage this little guy feeds on
plankton by cramming itself in the coral
the seahorse can intercept food as it
floats by and by perfectly matching its
surroundings it can avoid ending up in a
stomach itself it's just got to stay
very still that means you Waldo